Speaker 1: Hey, this is absolutely unbelievable.
Secret Service was warned on the eve of January
six, 2021, that there would be a risk to Mike
Pence caused by Donald Trump and his inciting
on January 5th and January 6th. This is this is
truly incredible. The Secret Service assigned to
Mike Pence warned Pence might be a target because
of Trump article on Axios. Marc Short, the then
chief of staff to former Vice President
Mike Pence, warned the Secret Service
on January five of a security threat to Pence per
the New York Times. The day before the Capitol
riot short warned his top Secret Service agent,
Tim Gables, that former President Trump may turn
against Pence and there could be a security
risk to Pence because of it. A source with
direct knowledge confirmed to Axios the report
was accurate. So both Axios and New York Times
independently able to confirm this short did
not have knowledge of the specifics of the
security threat, and it's not clear what steps,
if any, Gables took to respond to the warning.
The warning was the only time that short flagged
a security concern during his time as Pence's top
aide and understand what that what that means.
Okay. In the entire time that as Vice President
Mike Pence had Secret Service protection, there
was never a specific threat flag to Secret Service
by the Pence entourage or team. At the very
end of the Trump Pence regime, one such threat
was communicated to Secret Service. And the reason
for that threat was Donald Trump. The only threat
that Pence's staff had to communicate to Secret
Service during the entire time Mike Pence was vice
president was one precipitated by and caused
by his own president that Pence served under.
Think about that. A CNN had a report on this.
Speaker 2: Listen it. Also in our Politics Lead,
new details today about what the Secret Service
was told ahead of the January six insurrection
and of course, its mob chanting, Hang Mike Pence.
Hang Mike Pence. According to The New York Times,
Maggie Haberman, the vice president's
chief of staff, Marc Short,
warned Pence, his lead Secret
Service agent, on January
5th, a Donald Trump could turn against
the vice president publicly and there
could be a security risk to the vice president.
Speaker 1: Now, also relevant is if they knew on
January 5th, it's very clear that what took place
on the sixth was at least expected and predicted
by way more people than they've admitted.
Speaker 2: Because of it. Let's get let's
get it from the horse's mouth. New York Times
reporter Maggie Haberman, who has uncovered this
for her upcoming book, Confidence Man, which
comes out in October. Maggie, just to take
a step back here, I mean, the idea that the
vice president's chief of staff told the US
Secret Service that the president was going to be
responsible for a potential security risk to the
vice president. I mean, that's quite something.
Speaker 5: It's remarkable, Jake. And it's really
not a story about the Secret Service. This is a
story about the enormous concern that existed,
about the growing pressure that Donald
Trump was putting on his vice president,
this extraordinary dynamic where he was, you know,
becoming increasingly aggressive in his commentary
about a number of officials. But as he was trying
to force hands to essentially throw the Electoral
College Trump's way or at least back two states on
January 6th, and the fact that people around Pence
recognized that there was a potential safety risk
because of this, because the former president has
this, you know, mob of of very ardent supporters
who follow what he says. Now, do I think now they.
Speaker 1: Of course, were chanting Hang Mike
Pence at a period of time on January six,
2021. These are exactly the types of stories
that we said when Trump left. It's going to take
potentially years to learn about all of these
things to some degree, because journalists
are holding it for their books, and we've already
commented on that. So I won't comment on it again.
The one threat that had to be brought to
Pence's Secret Service detail originated
from President Trump. Let that sink in. Send me
your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at D Pacman.